[Music]
welcome to the quick start for Google
cloud persistent disks from the VM
instance page select your instance by
clicking on its name in the VM instance
details page select edit scroll down to
the additional disk section and then
click add item click on the name and
create disk in the new dialog that shows
up enter new - disk for the name and
change the disk type to standard
persistent disk under source type select
none blank disk and then set the size to
500 gb click create now back to the VM
instance details page you would have to
scroll down and then select save we will
now confirm the persistent disk has been
created to do that click SSH to connect
to the new SSH terminal it may take some
time to connect some times but once it
connects let's type in sudo LSB LK and
then the command sudo mkfs ext4 - m 0 -
f - e lazy underscore itable underscore
in it equals 0 comma lazy underscore
journal underscore in it equals 0 comma
discard slash dev slash s DB this will
format the attached disk and you will
see the inode tables that are writing
now note this may take a little bit long
so we will wait for it to format almost
there
once it's done formatting you can create
a mount directory with this command sudo
mkdir - p /mnt
slash disk slash my mount dir and then
mounted with this command sudo mount -
OH
discard
, defaults /dev /s DB / mount / disc
sash my mount dir finally change the
permissions on the desk by using sudo
chmod A plus W on the mount directly
well congratulations you've completed
this quick start
[Music]